الجمال وكل ما يخص الجمال يجتمع في مكان
واحد في بوليفارد حوال للجمال الذي يجمع
الماركات العالميه وغيرهم من خبراء تجميل
عالميين ومحليين ضمن فعاليات موسم الرياض
[موسيقى]
الاضواء سلطت على تقنيات المكياج الحديثه
وتسريحات الشعر من خلال ورش العمل التي
قدمها خبراء التجميل في مختلف القاعات
الداخليه والخارجيه
لديكم مدينه جميله
لاتحدث عن الجمال والعنايه الشخصيه التي
يجب التحلي بها
اول مره ناس كثير قوي تشوف شغلي ولاين
بتاعي فده حاجه يعني بسطاني ان انا هفرجهم
على اللاين
تواجد المؤثرات في مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي في بوليفارد حواء لتقديم نصائح
الجمال وتطبيقها على العارضات يعني انا
اليوم موجوده
اليوم كثير فعلا جايه من بره همم ودي اشوف
اليوم ايش الورشات راح يقدمونها واكون جزء
طبعا من حدث زي هذا يهم المراه ويهم
البنات في حدث ضخم زي ما موسم بالرياض
بوليفارد حوا بالجمال بما ان البنت
الخليجيه والسعوديه مهتمه بالاناقه مهتمه
بالجمال مهتمه بالمكياج فهذا الحدث راح
يغطي كل شيء والبنات اللي هنا جايين
يستمتعون بالجو بالاجواء ويستفيدون بنفس
الوقت انا داعيني موسم الرياض خصوصا هذا
اليوم اللي فات حواء عشان اي اغطي
الفعاليات اللي موجوده عشان احضر الكلاسات
واشوف همم الفنانين الميك اب والشعر اللي
جايبينهم هنا وايضا عشان التقي بمتابعاتي
واشوف شنو يحتاجون من معلومات واشاركهم
هذا الشيء المعرض الاول من نوعه في موسم
من الرياض لجمال المراه جماعه الاف
الفتيات والنساء المهتمات بالجمال كما خلق
شريحه جديده من الراغبات بالانضمام للمعرض
للمواصم القادمه
من الرياض شهد المتروك العربيه